إنه ليس سجلاً عنفًا لسيطرة طالبان
على الأراضي التي يفرون منها ليس داعش أو
الضربات الجوية التي لا مثيل لها من قبل التحالف ،
ولكن مع طردهم أخيرًا من
منازلهم ، فإنهم يهربون بدلاً من ذلك من
الجفاف وهو موجة جفاف قياسية أجبرت المزيد من
العائلات في أفغانستان على ترك منازلهم
هذا العام أكثر من  لقد كانت الحرب كما لو أن
أفغانستان لم تكسر بالفعل جميع
صيغ التفضيل بسبب بؤسها ، فهذا هو ما
يدفعهم لمقابلة
مشاة البحرية وابنتها أكيلا البالغة من العمر ست سنوات ، كنت تعتقد أن
عائلة صغيرة متحدة تحت
أغطية بلاستيكية
ولكن اليأس يعني ذلك  لم يتحول
الأمر بهذه الطريقة ، باعت مارين أكيلا مقابل
3000 دولار لهذا الرجل نجم الدين الذي
سيعطيها لابنه البالغ من العمر عشر سنوات شارك
آرغو ،
استمع إلى كيف وصلوا إلى هنا في مشاة البحرية
أولاً هربت من قريتي وهي تقول مع
أطفالي الثلاثة  بسبب الجفاف الشديد
، أتيت إلى هنا معتقدة أنني سأتلقى بعض
المساعدة
ولكن ليس لدي شيء لتجنب المجاعة
بين أطفالي ، فقد أعطيت ابنتي
لرجل مقابل حوالي 3000 دولار ولكني حصلت على
70 دولارًا فقط  حتى الآن لم يكن لديّ نقودهم لا طعام
ولا معيل لقُتل زوجي أيضًا.
لا تعرف أنني
بعتها كيف يمكن أن تعرف أنها طفلة ،
ماذا لو حاولت أكيلا الركض ، نسأل
عما إذا كانت تبكي أو تضحك تقول
أكيلا  ستضطر إلى الذهاب من سيبيع
قطعة من قلبها ما لم يضطروا حقًا
إلى مشتري أكويلا ،
تعتقد نجمة دين أن شراء فتاة تبلغ من العمر ست سنوات
هو عمل خيري للأسرة ليس
لديها أي شيء يأكله ، كما يقول جائع
وأنا أعلم '  أنا فقير أيضًا ، لكنني متأكد من أنه يمكنني
سدادها ببطء في غضون عامين أو ثلاثة
أعوام ، يسأل المصور عن ذلك ، لكن فيما يتعلق بأطفالهم
بشأن الموسيقى ، لا يهم أنه يقول إن
هذه الأشياء تحدث هنا يحدث
أيضًا أن نجما عميد قد فر أيضًا من الجفاف الذي تقول الأمم المتحدة
لقد وضع 275 ألف شخص في
حالة تنقل هذا العام حوالي نصفهم من
جميع أنحاء منطقة المعمدانيين ،
لقد خذلنا محصول القمح ، كما يقول ، لم نتمكن من
زراعة البطيخ ، فشلت جميع المحاصيل الأخرى
بسبب الجفاف ، فقدنا
ماشيتنا وأبقار الأغنام و  مات جميع الماعز
من الجوع حيث لم يكن هناك أي
علف  بالنسبة لهم في جميع أنحاء المخيم ، نسمع
هذا النوع من القصص المروعة التي تتكرر
هنا هذا الرجل باع ابنته البالغة من العمر أربع
سنوات لرجل يبلغ من العمر 20 عامًا
لتسوية موتاها ، إنه عالم من البقاء
وخيارات لا يمكن تصورها حيث يجب على العائلات أن
تخون بعضها البعض فقط.  للعيش
والشتاء قادم واعدًا بأن يكون أكثر برودة
مثل الزواج والجوع من نيك باتون
والش سي إن إن